Democrats race against reality that's
the subject of tonight's angle all right
when they're cornered and they're out of
options
Democrats have a nasty but it's a really
predictable habit of racializing
everything they did it to Reagan they
did it to Bush they even did it to
McCain and of course they did it to
Romney and they've been doing it to
Donald Trump since the day he announced
his candidacy first we have to deal with
the fact that the xenophobic ran he went
on on and on about about Mexicans and
them being racing I mean it was horrible
God even the notion that he talks in
seems fictitious it's very strong the
word no it's not too strong a word I
mean I also think it's racist I think we
can use that word well it didn't work
then and it won't work now but they're
trying yesterday senators Durbin and
Graham they wanted to fight their
bipartisan daca deal on the president
and by the way dick and Lindsay's
immigration act is about as viable these
days as Siegfried and Roy's okay we've
seen this before
well they pranced up to the White House
for the grand unveiling and they were
flummoxed when immigration stalwarts
Congress have got Bob Goodlatte from
Virginia and Senator Tom cotton of
Arkansas were already in the room as was
White House policy advisor immigration
expert Stephen Miller remember just a
few days earlier when the cameras were
rolling the president said he would not
sign any daca
without the funding of his wall and an
end to chain migration and that stupid
visa lottery system yet somehow the
dynamic duo thought that they could
through charm and flattery alone con
Trump into agreeing to their solution
that didn't meet the president's
baseline and actually if you can believe
it their idea increased chain migration
the president to their faces said it was
dead on arrival good for him Durbin and
Graham were so enraged after being
spurned
somebody went to the press they peddled
the story that Trump had referred to
Haiti and unspecified African countries
as s holes and that we should try to get
Norwegian immigrants here instead his
comments said things which were
hate-filled
vile and racist calling the nation's
they come from the exact word used by
the president not more not just once but
repeatedly now the president in a tweet
this morning denied that he used that
language and Durban clarified later that
the president was referring to African
countries whose citizens regularly use
the visa lottery system not Haiti itself
now setting aside the alleged remark for
a moment would you describe any of these
countries as shangri-la I mean if people
there were living in Club Med they
wouldn't be trying to crash our borders
and I think it's important don't you
think at this point after all the
verbiage to take a look at some of the
real facts about a few of the countries
that can't keep their own people from
leaving now let's begin with El Salvador
a country I've been to many times that
I've known very well for the last 30
years
it's capital has the highest murder rate
in the world
Somalia well guess what it's one of the
largest state sponsors of terrorism has
one of these is a safe haven for
terrorists across the globe and then of
course Sudan it's one of the four
countries on the u.s. state sponsors of
terror lists in addition to a lot of
other bad facts now I would not have
called these countries what the
President did but they are ranked with
corruption repression and of course it's
obvious isn't it that they offer their
citizens little hope of a better life in
other words they're hellholes
but for the Democrats and their media
allies who are forever feigning an
affinity for the third world facts don't
matter afterall race-baiting the
president is so much more fun president
white-supremacist that is absolutely
racism
steroids the President of the United
States is racist we voted for a racist
they're not whole countries for one
Donald Trump isn't their president we
have in the White House
someone who could lead the Ku Klux Klan
somebody who could be the leader of the
neo-nazi when it came to the issue of
quote chain migration I said to the
president do you realize how painful
that term is to so many people
African Americans believe that they
migrated to America in Chains now of all
the things I've ever heard tricky dick
durbin say that one perhaps could take
the cake now it seemed really suggesting
that the term chain migration which has
been part of the vernacular surrounding
the immigration debate for decades
constitute some type of hidden racism
it's a cold language well I think maybe
he's been talking to Joe Biden unchain
Wall Street
they're gonna put y'all back in Chains
guys booing in the crowd he had already
too many mimosas early in the morning
well all of this demonstrates that the
Democrats Durbin and all the rest they
had no real intention of working with
the President on a dock a deal I really
don't think they did because if they
were truly concerned for these daca kids
dreamers upwards of 30 years of age well
column kids well they would give a
little and then they get a little they
knew the president couldn't accept what
they were offering but we know now what
the real story is they had zero
intention of negotiating in good faith
because somehow they thought they could
guilt the president into siding with
them but I guess they don't really know
him very well do they they are out of
ideas and they have no solutions the
race card is the only one they have left
to play but look
despite the racial smears the unfairness
of it all look at what Trump has already
done for black America black
unemployment is at its lowest level
since the Bureau of Labor Statistics
started reporting the data back in 1972
it's at 6.8%
you know what it was in the middle of
Obama's first term 16.8% black family
income fell by more than $900 per family
during the Obama years fell just in the
first eight months of the Trump
administration black family income has
risen by more than $1,000 I'll take that
direction any day of the week with
Chrysler now announcing plants moving
from Mexico to the United States the
stock market booming and wages rising
across the country due to Trump's tax
cut backs America will thrive listen to
Gary from Texas a caller on my radio
show this morning who expressed I bet
how a lot of minorities really feel
about this manufactured controversy were
you offended by what you heard the
president say as an African American man
not at all he's trying to fight for this
country and your black sheep opportunity
to get off these streets we can't do it
if we keep bringing folks all over the
world with problems in that country that
doesn't mean we have to bring them over
here and come into our city and then
push our people back well those are the
people the president is fighting for
people who want more economic
opportunities they're not anti-immigrant
but they want to take care of Americans
first the veterans sleeping on the
street tonight
those with no opportunities those who
work hard but somehow maybe along the
way got addicted to opioids they need
help and no matter what Durbin or CNN
says that is a fact the silent majority
feels that the system is unfair and you
bet they want it fixed and when Trump
demands a better deal on immigration one
that's going to secure the border and
keep illegals from competing with our
citizens like that caller for jobs that
they need and he's fighting on behalf of
all citizens
the president's fighting for blacks
whites Hispanics Asians you're here
legally you're an American citizen he's
fighting for you
and that's the angle